the sheriff's deputy criticized by the
president says waiting outside the
school was the right move Scott Peterson
made his first public statement
yesterday nearly a week after he was
suspended and then resigned over his
response to that shooting Manuel
Bojorquez is outside Stoneman Douglas
high in parkland Florida with the latest
on this story Manuel good morning good
morning Scott Peterson's attorney says
allegations his client is a coward and
failed to meet the standards of police
officers are quote patently untrue
he said Peterson's heart goes out to the
families of the 17 victims and he wishes
he could have prevented their deaths
Broward County sheriff's deputies Scott
Peterson is pushing back against some of
his biggest critics including President
Trump we saw Peterson standing outside
of that school he wanted no part of it
and Broward County Sheriff Scott Israel
I was disgusted I was just a moralized
with the performance of former deputy
Peterson in a statement defending his
actions Peterson's attorney says his
client initially received a call of
firecrackers and not gunfire and ran to
the three-story building where the
shooting occurred
that's where Peterson heard gunshots but
believed they were coming from outside
consistent with his training mr.
Peterson took up a tactical position at
a corridor or corner between two nearby
buildings radio transmissions about a
possible victim by the football field
served to confirm mr. Peterson's belief
that the shooter or shooters were
outside when there's over a hundred
rounds being fired from inside of one
building you know where those rounds are
coming from Broward Sheriff's Office
deputies Association president Jeff Bell
is critical of Peterson's claims and
points to the 1999 Columbine massacre
that changed how law enforcement respond
to active shooters with Columbine it was
a long time before those SWAT teams got
there and we lost innocent lives because
of that delay we are now trained that we
can't wait for SWAT anymore so the first
arriving units on scene you got to make
that decision to go in Peterson's
attorney said Peterson is the one who
initiated a Code Red lockdown at the
school and told administrators to review
camera footage to identify the shoe
the Sheriff's Office declined to comment
on Peterson's claims saying his conduct
remains part of an ongoing internal
investigation John Manuel sang